over a year ago now it was announced
that we were going to be getting a
Battlestar Galactica movie and TV series
but nothing seems to have happened since
are they dead in the water
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
good morning Starbucks what are you here
nothing but the rain grab your gun and
bringing the cat
[Music]
ronaldinh Moore's Battlestar Galactica
reboot was a Triumph particularly for me
the mini series the mini series was just
epic television and it was a genuinely
brilliant
um spectacle and I just wish honestly it
was maybe a little bit before his time
because could you imagine sort of
streaming Network money a few years
later and that project it could have
been even better and Sam Ismail and
Simon kimberg are hoping to recreate
that Brilliance with a movie and TV
series Sam Ismail is hoping to put a
television series that will be in the
same universe as the movie on the
peacock Network and Simon kingberg is
looking to do a cinematic reboot of the
Battlestar Galactica original movie now
both of these projects are apparently
still within the same universe as Ronald
D Moore's version and apparently Sam
ismail's Actually spoken to Randy Moore
and actually got his permission to do
this which is something he said he felt
was important to do it's like asking for
a young lady's hand in marriage you ask
the dad first right
[Music]
a few months ago I actually got a little
bit of leaked information that the plot
was going to be based around the cylons
the human
um hybrids that the cylons created and
obviously the escape and colonists and
that that was going to be the three-way
battle that the hybrid is going to end
up attacking the humans but end up
turning on the cylons during the
conflict and then actually helping the
human colonists for the rest of the
series now the Battlestar Galactica
movie has been on the cards for years
nearly a decade Brian Singer was
initially signed on to
um direct and produced the movie and
then since then there's been a long list
of names and Jack paglin Lisa Joy John
Olaf Francis Lawrence the name goes on
and on and on but the currently it's
still on the IMDb list for Simon
kingberg along with a million other
projects honestly his IMDb for projects
over the next two years is about 30 see
long he there is no way I know he's a
producer so he can drop in and out of
projects but
something's got to give and I think that
is going to be part of the problem so
what have I been told I obviously have
spoken to people I know within the
industry and generally speaking the
feeling is that right now these projects
are dead now the Battlestar Galactica TV
series for peacock could go ahead at any
point but it won't because it is
inexorably linked with the movie now as
I said Sam Ismail has talked a lot um at
the start of last year about how the
projects for the movie and the TV series
were intertwined with each other that
they were going to be existing within
the same universe and that there was a
lot of work being done to make sure that
they complemented each other
so the movie has now been put on hold
there is no news about when it's going
to happen but why is that projects like
Deadpool 3 Whalen Artemis and the
Running Man have just took precedent he
these projects are currently in
production he actually looking at his
IMDb and looking at his work history
over the last few years he tends to have
four or five projects actually in
production at any one point this guy
seriously works hard
but those projects have just overtaken
the bow style Galactica project and put
it on the back burner I'm also being
told though that there is just not so
much money in sci-fi as there was a
couple of years ago there isn't as much
confidence in putting money into a
project like Battlestar Galactica as
there was a couple of years ago most
genres do go within Ebbs and flows and
sci-fi at the moment is in a little bit
of a decline there just isn't the big
sci-fi projects on the horizon that like
we have had over the last few years like
June coming up and things like that
now this happens because basically a
movie will come out that's massively
popular and then lots of other
production companies want to copy that
movie so you get sort of like spurts of
films that are very similar to each
other so sci-fi would have an increase
say following the early success of Star
Trek and Star Wars and all these sorts
of things so other production companies
fake white people like sci-fi let's make
sci-fi
well it sounds a bit different
we're getting a lot of superhero movies
at the moment they will decline you'll
notice that we're getting a lot of sort
of romantic comedies appearing on
cinematic lists at the moment that's
because one or two have been reasonably
successful I'm thinking back to Notting
Hill all those years ago that really
kick-started the last time we had a
revolution of rom-coms and it's the same
thing now you get one or two successes
other production companies come
competent and they put the money in
those sort of films so you get a story
of those films at the moment there's not
a lot of confidence in sci-fi it may
also be another reason why they're
delaying the Stargate project that we're
so desperately waiting for
you have to remember that these
production companies are run by human
beings at the end of the day and they
are investing tens even hundreds of
millions of dollars they have to be
reasonably confident in what they're
going to do will actually make money and
in this case in Battlestar Galactica
they're not certain now this has not
been canceled it does seem that it's
just being put back while other projects
are taking precedent but the problem is
for the TV series that it's not going to
get done unless the movie does that
these really do go hand in hand and the
chances are we're not going to get one
without the other
so we're just waiting we're in a holding
pattern seeing if actually Simon
kingberg can get this up and running or
whether it will be just pushed back
again and again because of other
projects
I should say that this film was supposed
to be in production now they were
supposed to have got a director around
March or April last year they haven't
and then they were going to produce the
movie within eight to nine months of
that point so director around March film
around now they don't have a director
now so I don't think even if they do get
off their backsides and get this sorted
we'll be seeing Battlestar Galactica on
our screens before maybe mid 2025 and
the TV series sometime after that
so guys get in the comments is the
Battlestar Galactica reboot something
you desperately want to see or does you
like prefer a continuation of the story
do we really need to see this hard
reboot of the original story do we need
to see the cylons attack in the colonies
for a third time or actually what a
continuation of the story be way more
interesting get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
really upset and if you want to really
support the channel consider hitting the
join button there's also links to lots
of our websites like the nine Chevron
website which we do all of our Stargate
news our merchandise website our Discord
server our Facebook page all of the
links are in the description as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
foreign
[Music]